- Those shoes are amazing.
- Dude, you know why they're awesome?
They're not stilettos.
I give up on stilettos.
- I know [Laughs].
- They hurt me.
Whatever. I'm getting too old for that.
You've got two huge
shows that you're doing.
- Kelly
- Yeah, you're killing it.
- Oh my gosh. It's a good time.
- Yeah, it is a good time.
- I'm having a "me
season" as Issa Rae says.
I'm having a "me season".
- That's what I'm calling 2022.
But wait, you actually
got started in music.
I was just talking to you
about this a minute ago.
I didn't know that.
- Yeah, I did.
- You sang opera?
- I went to music school at Northwestern.
I sang opera for a little
while and then I, you know,
came to New York shortly
thereafter and tried to
get a record deal.
- [Kelly] Yeah
- Like I was in the music industry
and I love, love, loved
it, but it was really hard.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I felt like record company executives
weren't for me necessarily
in art, in music.
- [Kelly] I've worked with several
(laughs)
there's only been a
couple that I've liked.
- It's very hard. Do you know what I mean?
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah.
- I was really into the
music, and they were really
into the money, and you couldn't
find a middle ground so...
- It is hard because they
find, they're like, oh
this is working.
So we want you to do this.
- All the time.
- Well, I would like to do what I do.
- No, I wanna grow, right.
- Yeah.
- And it wasn't really possible
- But they see it as a
business. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
- They do.
- Yeah, yeah. They do.
Not. All of them are like that
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
but yes, a lot of them are.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. But
- But I still sing.
- I love that.
- I love to sing.
- I know you need to do
like a movie musical now.
Now I wanna see you in that.
- I want to too, but I also
do a lot of car karaoke
to Kelly Clarkson.
- You do?
Do you actually love karaoke?
When you go to karaoke-
Wait, if you go, what is your go to?
I like to rap.
- Well-
Oh, rap is good.
- Rap is good. Cuz
people expect me to sing.
So that's why I always rap.
- Well I love a lot of Celine Dion.
- Yes. All coming back to me now.
Pound chest now.
(Guest sings)
- Yeah. And I, I mean, I,
I mean, I'm saying this
but I do mean I do a lot
of Kelly Clarkson because
your songs are great.
- Oh, thank you.
- Great songs. - Thank you.